there's no business like show
business and this next comic is one of
the best in the business
please welcome they nab johnson
hey hey hey it's so lovely to be back on
the banana more stage how is everybody i
have a really quick story
and then i'm gonna go okay so if you
know anything about me you know i love
dessert
like cakes cookies pies i love it if you
put a thanksgiving spread in front of me
and then put a cake i'm going for the
cake first like
dinner is basically the warm-up dessert
is the workout dinner
is the foreplay dessert is the orgasm
okay so i was visiting my sister
a couple of weeks ago and my sister made
me this amazing savory meal which i
ate but i wasn't satisfied because i
needed something sweet and my sister
who's trying to get back down to a size
two
only being a weak postpartum has
no sugar in her house period like her
husband can't even give her a kiss
because that would be too
sweet so my nephew who's 10 years old
he pulls me to the side and he starts
whispering to me like we're doing some
illegal transaction
and he's like auntie i have my four
ingredient peanut butter cookies i still
have some left if you want some
and me just like an addict i'm like yeah
i need it give it to me now so i follow
my nephew down to his like
secret lair and we get these peanut
butter cookies
and i inspect the cookies because he's a
kid he's 10 years old i'm not just
eating no kids cookies
so the cookies look good they have the
classic fork print on top of them they
smell good
i eat the cookies surprisingly they
taste really good so i'm like
nephew what are the four ingredients and
he's like oh i made a video i can just
show you the video of me making it
so i'm just eating a cookie while i'm
watching the video i put a cookie in my
mouth and i see him
wash his hands and then i put another
cookie in my mouth and i see him take
out the peanut butter
the vanilla extract the eggs the sugar
i put another cookie in my mouth right
as i'm eating the third cookie
i see my nephew on the video wipe his
feet with both his hands
he wiped his feet like he was lebron
james about to do the jump ball
at the start of a championship game i
said
did you wipe your feet and then put the
cookies together
and he was like did i i was like it's on
the video and he was like i didn't
realize i did it i was like okay okay
okay
the cookies are still good but they're
no longer four ingredient cookies
they're five ingredient cookies and the
fifth ingredient is a secret
that's it for me you guys thank you for
having me on banana morris until next
time
oh that's funny